science magazine presents art apotheca
reminisce the most detailed picture of
early hominid life on the cover of
science there is the partial skeleton of
a remarkable human ancestor this is
Ardipithecus ramidus and a team of
international researchers introduce this
hominid remember the human family that
lived 4.4 million years ago which is
about a million years older than Lucy's
species and they flesh it out and what
they are telling us in these 11 articles
is that it doesn't look just like us
which is not surprising you wouldn't
invite them to dinner but it doesn't
look just like a chimpanzee either which
is a big surprise so instead of thinking
of something in between a chimp and a
human we have to think of this as really
not a series of links in a chain as much
as branches in a tree and our branch is
a very peculiar branch we have very
strange feet in huge brains how did that
happen well we have to work our way back
down our branch and so we're getting
pretty close to the fork that was
between the line that led off to the
chimpanzees and the line that led off to
us and Ardipithecus takes us pretty far
back toward that branch and informs us
that the node point the junction the
last common ancestor was neither human
nor a chimpanzee it was something
entirely different it's living on the
ground walking upright like us spending
a lot of time walking upright if you saw
it walk by the walk would look a lot
like ours but it can't run like us the
skeleton we have is estimated to be
around 4 feet tall and to weigh around a
hundred hundred and ten pounds and so
that's why skeletons are important they
allow you to get at things like stature
limb proportions and and all of that and
I think one of the one of the things
that we would be most impressed by
seeing seeing Ardipithecus and in the
flesh would be the very small size of
her face and brain brain case the very
large size of her arms and
hands and this grasping ability of her
feet she had a foot with an opposable
large toast first time we've ever seen
this in a fossil hominid all the rest of
them even the Lucy species fairly early
at 3.7 23.2 and even with footprints in
the footprints the large toe is right in
line with the other toes there's already
an arch to the foot
Arty's foot was not like that when Artie
walked it towed off of the lateral four
digits and the large toe was off to the
side acting more in stabilization
instead of in toe off and so it's a very
different creature what that does what
the maintenance of that grasping foot
does for you is to open up the arboreal
environment Ardipithecus ramidus hands
and forearms weren't as stiff as a
modern chimpanzee or gorillas if your
knuckle walking going like this you need
to have a very stiff wrist and you need
to have fingers that can handle that
weight and all the forces there's all
sorts of adaptations that are Deepika
stid not have it had a much more
flexible hand and wrist so it was able
to free up the hands to do other things
so it turns out that that last common
ancestor was probably not a knuckle
Walker at all knuckle walking evolved
independently in gorillas and in chimps
and that's really one of the biggest
lessons of Ardipithecus is that we can't
just take a modern animal like a chimp
or gorilla and use it as a proxy for the
last common ancestor chimps and gorillas
have been evolving for 6 & 7 million
years - and so what we're seeing here is
something that we never could have
predicted from either a modern human or
a modern chimpanzee the only way to
learn about this creature is through the
paleontological record in addition to
our topi thickest ramidus which was the
rare creature in this landscape were
over 6,000 specimens of animals that
this team uncovered ranging in size from
elephants and shrews and hyenas and
antelopes and monkeys to tiny rodents
all pellets
bats we also have snails we have fossil
wood fossils seeds we have fossil
millipedes we have birds we have very
small mammals and all of these very
sensitive environmental indicators build
up to a picture of a woodland habitat
that's now been sampled just by
geological forces where the exposures of
this ancient horizon are present it's it
used to be very different from what it
is today the traditional view for the
past 50 years has been that our
ancestors arose in the grassy savannahs
of Africa this is where autopathic is
ramidus is so important that 4.4 million
years ago already shows us a creature
that was walking in an intermediate way
developing upright walking but it's not
fully modern yet and it was living in
the woods
it wasn't living in the open savanna it
wasn't using tools and its brain was the
size of a chimpanzee it used to be a
closed wooded habitat full of monkeys
and ku dews and with a few Ardipithecus
and 6,000 fossils plus all of the
invertebrates and all of the other
isotopic data from soils and things like
that lead up to the same conclusion and
this is a very different conclusion I
think than most people expected of the
earliest hominids because many people
thought that bipedality and the earliest
hominids had evolved in more open
savanna settings where I think
researchers will have the most doubt
about this analysis of Ardipithecus
ramidus is in the proposal that it is a
snapshot of the primitive member of the
human family and the primitive ancestor
we shared with chimpanzees and gorillas
that it shows us that that ancestor did
not look like a chimpanzee or gorilla if
we were a couple of chimps sitting here
talking about our ancestor we'd have
very little to say because there's
almost no fossil record of chimpanzees
and was not in fact until a few years
ago
we now have a handful of teeth from
about 500,000 which are very interesting
but they don't tell us a whole lot about
the whole evolution of chimpanzees there
are no fossil gorillas either and so if
we knew these lineages we'd know a lot
more about ourselves as well and partly
because of this it's been assumed that
the last common ancestor of humans and
chimps was rather chimp-like and that's
it you can't deny it because you have no
evidence that chimps were any different
then than they are now the significance
of this is that it's earlier in time
nearer the last common ancestor and if
we want to know what the less common
ancestor was and to try and understand
the forces that led to our divergence
from a chimpanzee ancestor this is much
more relevant we began to work in the
middle of Washington 1981 we really
didn't know what was going to be found
this is long term protracted scientific
research endeavor and this kind of work
does actually take decades it doesn't
take that long if you don't find
anything but we've found a great deal
we've found something like 15 separate
horizons in this kilometer of rock that
have yielded hominid fossils we have
over 18,000 vertebrate fossils thousands
of artifacts from multiple horizons
Ardipithecus is one snapshot within that
depository but it's the best snapshot
and it's the most detailed snapshot it
is the most data rich snapshot there are
so few skeletons of fossil humans that's
I don't know four or five and you can
tell so much more when you've got a
whole skeleton than when you've got a
few bits and pieces even if you've got
bits of different parts of the skeleton
knowing that they're all associated in
one an individual is really exciting the
interpretations that go along with it
are very provoking some of them are
undoubtedly true I'm sure others will be
topics of discussion for a good while
but the basic data I think is what
really counts here and the fact that
you've got a fairly complete skeleton
you've got a lot of other associative
things
is what's at this particular time period
is what's really significant about this
puzzle I think some researchers will
agree that because Ardipithecus ramidus
shows these traits that are different
from a chimpanzees or gorillas that that
tells us that it inherited them from an
ancestor that those are primitive traits
other researchers will say no those are
changes that arose in Auto Pittacus
ramidus is lineage that it diverged from
the ancestors of chimpanzees and
gorillas and lost traits that are in
their line so this is forcing wholesale
rethinking about the models of why we
began walking upright why we went
through social changes that set us apart
from the other Apes and sent us down the
path toward humanists
the name Ardipithecus ramidus is based
on an off our name for ground RT and
remedy for root and so if you want to
think of it that way it's kind of like
the root of the ground Apes we in the
middle I wash project try to respect the
local culture by naming when we can
the scientific name based on and off our
root science is published by triple-a s
the science Society